this family-run restaurant is located at
a very busy intersection yet they can't
get those customers to walk through
their door I'll be going undercover as a
member on a weekly pop-up my god
Oh feel that tight knots behind it's
hard [ __ ]
[Music]
other possible I don't want stick down
my cleavage I'll be selfies down no no
no nails Libby Lou ready for a ladies
lunch trust me this one's gonna be a
page-turner
Wilfried the [ __ ] out all about this
the old kid
no drink no drinking that in common
hey you ready to see something that's
quite possibly you no no you ready to
see your dad I'm use I know he's not
your dad anymore
get ready it's your mommy right now
listen I'm coming back in two weeks time
for an operation I need to talk to look
at but you holy
I'm sorry okay I'll give you a call
later okay do you have fun no manners
okay Nancy I'm sorry okay
don't screenshot it and don't tell your
mom I'll tell her that okay just one
more little look at my feet just couple
of issues your varicose veins I'll get
them done for Christmas I'm good how are
you I have someone who wants to say
quick you guys want to say a quick hi
yeah hold on here he's right next to me
here oh hello mate
I'll be job I've been trying to tell you
for a long time you got two mommies now
I've got problem with the varicose vein
but the doctor said they can do the
operation
dude what do you think it suits me your
screenshotting this thing you little
bastard I'll talk to you later it's
making their bike no I'm not enjoying do
them and holding it in so if these start
lopsided lift them up a little bit I'll
just just give you some pointers shall
we
toys in there penny oh Jesus there's no
rap in there